first keeping his hands up like a good
old boxer oh that's so stupid one of the
greatest knockdowns of all time I've
always said if you don't have taekwondo
you're probably not going to be a
champion you see how you see his defense
did you see you see the shoulder roll
that Anderson did so the that's he's
thrown I'll keep you the distance right
now yes like look at his distance he's
not really taking hits Now watch how
hard he is to hit you see that you see
how he's off the center line every time
he throws
fundamentals go as far as straight
boxing goes Anderson's gonna have the
upper hand on Jake 100 yeah of course my
money's on I have to put my money on you
know
so Anderson so I mean it makes sense and
I know again I think I stand for it you
have to go I know you have to go with
Jake and I appreciate you I respect your
friendship I like that you're there for
your boy and if Jake beats him I'm gonna
be give some respect I already have
respect for him but I'm going to be a
lot more right yeah